on june 25th that is in a couple weeks
tiger belly will be doing our first live
show at the ace theater in los angeles
um so please go to
tigerbellylive.com we want to see you
there it's going to be a night of music
magic
mystery dreams extravaganza mystery
um so yeah i'm really excited to see you
guys um we can't wait we know it's been
a long time coming we've been wanting to
go on the road for a while this is our
first date so
hope to see you there you can also see
this young man in st louis missouri this
weekend at the funny bone june 4th and
5th i'm so excited then i'll be in
houston texas at the improv june 10th
and 12th then here locally in burbank
california at flappers comedy club june
18th just one show only west niagara new
york june 25th through 20
24th through 25th then um i'm taking
july off and you can see me in august in
springfield missouri
um september oh there's a bunch of dates
just go online there's a bunch of dates
i'm going to a bunch of places but these
tickets will sell out the meet and
greets have been just absolutely on fire
i love meeting you guys i love signing
merch for you i have new merch coming i
also have a spotify show audio show
coming out um it will be premiering june
27th so that'll be fun
i'll see you guys there you guys i'm
coming to washington dc austin
oh i think phoenix esther on ice.com and
also sleepoverbaster.com
and that's it we love you follow me and
all of us on tick tock follow us on tick
tock i have a new tick tock
i actually like big do you like big ears
on guys i like when i guys ears are
poked out a little i
like ugly dudes so i don't know
i don't think there's a wrong person but
whenever i hear someone like getting
their ears pinned back i'm like let me
see like i understand if somebody's back
people do that yeah yeah yeah yeah look
at their ears pinned back that's one of
the og you get teased a lot in the
philippines for that there's a word for
it it's called dunk
it's like basically when you have dumbo
ears yeah what's that is danka uh like
asian no it's it's elephant
my mom got her ears pinned back really
cute before
um she
i think i thought really thought they
were cute before yeah jules has a little
bit of an audi and um i she doesn't want
to change it thank god she's just like
no i like it i like my little dance it's
cute to have your little dents yeah gen
z people like their
their ear issues i might get a nose job
that doesn't look like a nose job though
because i cannot breathe through my i'm
like this [ __ ] that's not a nose job
then that's just a matter of life if i
came out and they gave me a nose job i'd
be so pissed annie how about this
when i get it get it at the same time
let's do i just want a straight shot i
just want to be able to what do you want
to get that surgery too because i feel
like i have a hard time breathing
oh my god we're gonna all end up looking
so weird you know what i was told by my
doctor
it's a hormonal thing so it actually
happens to a lot of women as we get
older we start to have difficulty
getting air through our nasal passages
it's harder to queef too it's like all
of our passages wait a second
all the time annie where'd my queefs go
my queefs have arrived it
seems like where where were you all
these years like you never queef now
it's just that's all it is how
embarrassing on the sleepovers you
didn't get to be queef girl how
embarrassing is that when i jerk myself
off i'm queefing
are you fisting yourself or like
twisting hair and why are you queefing
at sleepovers no i wasn't the sleepover
girl but you know that squeeze a
sleepover girl no oh cause you never
stayed long enough
this [ __ ] made our whole you're such a
base on a lie your whole life is based
on no i'm obsessed with sleepovers
because i always had to go now you're
old enough to like not get picked up
yeah still call dave
there's no way you wouldn't like 20
minutes into our sleepover be like
this was a mistake i eat all my popcorn
and then i'm like i have to go home i
know we do have to have one at my house
because i have the popcorn i'm ready
which has not been cleaned in about six
months still ready can you tell me about
the queef and the sleep okay there was
always a girl that could queef on
command
i might quit
there was always a girl yeah tiffany
there's always a girl could suck it in
and
so this is just something like you do
around the fire yeah i was never i put
the fire out that's what i do
wait i have a question for the guys i'm
not a good queefer is carlos
no matter what your sexual identity is
doesn't matter
but what are your thoughts on queefs
like is is it make guys cringe when
girls talk about it no it doesn't make
me cringe i've heard it we said guys
carlos not you
i've heard it in real life and i always
kind of ignore it so that like just
because you don't embarrass the i don't
want them to be embarrassed or anything
like it's natural but you know you
created that question yeah the queef is
like a cute like i always feel like we
should name it like it's our first kid
you know like we made this queef
together like you packed that hair in
how many kids i
how many episodes did it take for us to
spend the first 10 minutes of this this
is our wholesome five yeah it's going to
get crazy after this
um i um yeah i think i have a a queefing
problem oh i was like don't touch her i
thought you'd be like i feel like i have
a lump in my armpit i also did not look
like she was like telling us something
bad
but you know that's why i got a boob job
my whole life i've been obsessed with
just grabbing boobs like even my own
getting a boob job tomorrow i grab my
boobs so much and i love gra i will i
will grab anyone's boobs
i know i like your nails they remind me
of me i copied haley bieber in her
stroke video oh god isn't it just like
there's just some girls i you just can't
not copy so
i've been on hayley bieber forever i
know i'm so sorry i thought the stock of
her um um getting ready is that get
ready with me right before just one of
justin bieber's show and she hardly put
any makeup on and she looked flawless
and i'm like i got to turn this how old
is she though she's like 24. 25. she's
24.
okay but here's the thing that i brought
her up to whitney recently and whitney
was like esther why are you obsessed
with her she's in like a religious cult
yes but who care i don't know we don't
care okay that's why she's so beautiful
the lord loves her back
listen if you love god he loves you back
you know that right like ray leota is
not talking about god is he and he's got
the pock marks from hell okay
that's my favorite line from family guy
um when they called his face like a
decorative autumn squash
i used to do i used to do a joke about
when the chantix commercials were like
big i'm like i like ray liotta on the
chandex commercials he was like i tried
everything i tried the patch
i tried going cold turkey and i even
tried putting them out on my own face
really but even while i'm saying this i
actually do also like pockmarks though
also
teasing but i do like any little dent
you have in your life and we love a
celebrity who's willing to be
self-deprecating about yes but also he's
hot yeah he's hot he's rugged it's like
and you could tell he got bullied in
high school listen i'm all about the
boys that were bullied in high school
they have revenge they want to [ __ ] it
out of you you know what else guys who
didn't have sex in high school that's my
fetish yes but they have but that's
because they'll [ __ ] anyone
literally guys that wouldn't get laid
they literally
can't they can't say no oh my god
you guys um something really tragic
happens oh no why am i already laughing
why am i smiling why am i so excited
best part of the show is when kaleida
tells us something horrible
i like it better when she just tells us
something horrible without warning and
she does it like a happy voice
he punched me through the window and
then molested me when i was underage
what
look listen the reason i'm wearing
something so loose today is because i
got a sunburn in a place i have never
gotten a sunburn before and it's only in
one spot i forgot to put um spf and it's
right under my right boob crease and
what's that like to have a boob crease
can we see esther can we see
so bad yeah is it peeling hold on this
is such a cute outfit oh my god
do you see how bad it is that is really
bad you got some titties on it it looks
like you got it it looks like you got
chaffed up it looks like someone was
trying to [ __ ] that part of your boob
how did you get that sunburn um i
thought hey it's you know california
summer and i put i laid you know when
you how do you lay out under the sun or
like let's say you're at the beach face
down ass up i'm trying to get that
[ __ ] to even out with the rest of my
skin i don't know why it's such a
different color i tried a new move and
that was putting myself like on a baking
sheet like a turkey breast like this
and then it lifted my boob up but i
guess i didn't put it under the lining
of the two piece and it just took me out
right here i listen
we wear a bra i can't wear a bra
i've never seen you wear bra oh that's
right you wear like kind of like sports
bra bras but wait speaking of underboob
and that stuff so i've been okay so
annie i'm out
and for these reasons
so i
have been having some lower back
problems lately and i i was like i mean
they're not that big
she's like my my neck myth has been
debunked
say it's my lower back please please one
for your [ __ ] walks [ __ ] that she's
too huffing and puffing the top i knew
the minute i said my back was hurting i
was just gonna get a beating okay so i
thought maybe like because this is a new
in a new injury so i'm like okay maybe
it's from when i broke my toe like i'm
i'm compensating in a weird way still
hanging onto that towel i call it the
olympic toe i just realized what it's
from and it's kind of sad it's like i
realize that i have been
like protectively like
standing like this because my boobs are
starting to sag and like
basically i'm causing myself back pain
by living in denial and sitting like
this all the time this is why you're
getting rolls finally you're trying to
get cast and [ __ ] [ __ ]
stick those titties out we're gonna need
more numbers we need subscribers
when i relax they're just like a little
bit this is not how you're supposed to
sit this is actually helping people do
not say tmj when okay when i went to the
doctor for tmj he did this whole cat
scan then he he saw how i was standing
you have to be up like this and have
your chin back a little i know you're
trying to poke your chin forward [ __ ]
she is right i think that part of the
like but maybe you need to hold your
core it's a core too you gotta
strengthen the core but um
i have really bad posture so i have
nothing to say about that although i
will ask you guys is do people really
get their backs blown out during sex is
that a real thing what does that mean it
would have to be like doggy style and
they're pounding your ass like they're
folding you a little bit
you know they're like folding your ass
up like an accordion like
where your toes hit your neck you know
like this yes no not like fold but like
like folding it where your ass is going
to hit the back of your head i was
thinking more of like a compressed
spinal cord where it's like pushing in
so hard that it compresses from one
vertebrae to the neck you guys got to
get a hospital bed i'm telling you or is
it that guys blow their back out
[Music]
from yeah enough i know i've never done
that you just say you guys have to get a
hospital you gotta get i've been telling
you this for months nobody is like
catching on this is the wave of the
future you don't have to do anything he
doesn't have to thrust
they gotta make and by the way hospital
beds can you go faster
you guys thrust back
if i'm in a good mood
if i'm feeling charitable
well the worst is when you when when you
do when you're like all into and then
you [ __ ] the rhythm up and then like all
right
the rhythm is going to get you
the rhythm of the night it's where the
rhythm of the late afternoon i have a
question for you guys um have you ever
been
dropped by a friend or someone like over
like not being fully in alignment with
their political beliefs
i love when i just kill the energy
i know it's like we were really having
fun
there's a girl that i absolutely adore
to this day
and um she started kind of living
in like
that
i don't want to say it in a bad way
because people can have their own
beliefs about whatever but she started
to kind of go a little bit like
anti-vaxx like hippie conspiracy theory
type
like if you have dreads you like don't
believe in abortion like what is going
on she's probably also one of those
girls that like live off like volcano in
like um big island in hawaii you know
would love to go maybe you could take me
the day we leave she's in a volcano
are we brave enough to do a redo i don't
know tonight like we have to drag but
listen now we know we have to do we have
to tie her ankles together and just pull
her listen i will only go if it involves
like real activity i don't i like
shopping but shopping's funny okay
shopping lasts two days but the first
couple days i like going to two hours
two hours okay a spending limit and you
humiliate each other
this is very easy
but annie
and esther my we came to i love this
girl so much we've had such a great
relationship over the last eight years
like she is a part of my family so we
both decided that we were just gonna
never talk about it and we would shelf
the friendship until the country becomes
a little less
like everything becomes a little less
politicized so i'm just like i know her
heart i love her i'm always gonna like
look out for her but we're just not
gonna [ __ ] talk about it that's what
my so my two uncles my mom's two
brothers oh i got so excited you had gay
uncles
gungles
they're one is like very pro-trump and
one hates trump and they were getting
into fights a lot and now they just they
do they don't they just don't doesn't
come up they don't go there which i
think is a really good way to handle it
right because then then the machine
isn't working to divide
that's yeah i find the things that you
like
liked about the person never had
anything to do about politics i've never
met someone like wow our political
beliefs uh aligned like i never had any
of my [ __ ] protests i went to when i
was like i made friends for life i never
met one person i give a [ __ ] about at
all honestly i lie i don't even hang out
with anyone i put that [ __ ] out on with
i i bring this up because i
i kind of got dropped by a friend over
like political stuff a couple maybe like
a year or whatever ago or whatever it
was like i would say a year and seven
months ago i remember
it was i don't forget um
and
i'm like i find myself like when it
happens you know it's like oh everything
is going on in the world the pandemic
all the news and then like now that it's
been like a year and a half i'm like
that is so weird can i take this one
because i remember the situation yeah
but don't be like specific but i'm gonna
no no
this was what my take on this was
someone wanted to like have control over
you is what it seemed like they wanted
you to believe everything they believed
and the minute you were
because a lot of people when they get
like really heated about something they
don't want to be challenged and you not
going along with everything that she
wanted was challenging her and she
couldn't just tell you no we're all on
this team that we don't do these things
and we don't and it's just like you had
no freedom in that friendship it is yeah
and then it's probably embarrassing for
her to be friends with you now because
she
it was dumb what you did i think you're
right about the control thing it's like
because i i try now to always say like
well why can't we all have different why
can't i be friends with people who
believe different things than me i want
i want that like i don't know but i
think you're right that's like you have
to believe what i believe or you have to
do what i say like but it was like an
authority over it was almost like she
was but i think you kind of have that
too right where you like you kind of
like come to people like looking up to
them and then she really enjoyed that
role and the minute she realized like oh
that's not like oh a hundred percent all
the time this is making you feel some
type of way i'm shaking my foot your
foot no it was sad i know it's like sad
you know what it is it's sad to not be
friends with someone
that
feels like it's over something that is
so stupid but it probably wasn't that it
was probably something else and i think
it was probably like an underlying
experience but you have to no but it's
not you even let's say it was your
breath would that wouldn't that be her
being a [ __ ] and not you
do you know what i mean like it's just
whatever she was going through it's not
you yeah you just like she was able to
like that's true i don't take it
personally right and she was using you
as like a weakling that she could and
then when she realized that's not what
you were she didn't have room for a
person that was going to like challenge
her in her life it has nothing to do
with you
i i would have to agree with annie
really yeah on that i think it has
nothing that particular situation from
what you i know of it
has nothing to do with any political
views and would you want to be friends
with someone right now that was making
you feel bad about things no i don't i
don't i don't want to feel bad for that
pressure and your friendship no
have you have you had this happen to you
at all i mean i got friend dumped by
every girl i marched with i got like a
communal like
it was like it was just you know there's
like a mean girl situation going on when
if one person has a problem with you
everyone unfollows you you're like
what
okay
but i am so grateful for that i really
am because i was getting so worked up in
that friendship and really didn't feel
like it was a situation where i got
myself into it and i was like people
pleasing with this one friend and like
giving her so much of my which i think
you probably were doing with this other
one giving her so much like oh okay do
you want something like i was like
getting her presents for her birthday
like things like things that weren't
reciprocated that's on me that's not
like up to other people too but it just
wasn't like a healthy even
relationship and then it was the same
thing like when i wasn't like the louis
thing came out if i'm being candid when
the louis article came out and i read it
i was like i don't have the feelings
that other people have about this my
feelings are not like i don't i feel
like when there are consenting adults
that it's a different situation and i'm
not saying it's chill and great what
happened but i did not feel like it was
appropriate during the harvey weinstein
takedown to be equating what happened
with louie i just didn't i like i just
have a different feeling from the things
i went through yeah but you know more
and more people are starting to accept
the nuance of it all right hopefully you
know like during that time it's almost
like it had to swing one way so hard
and maybe it had to be that way at first
yeah but like my hope is that you know
as time goes we're able to see the
levels of this game it is just one hey
me too blanket that we're like hey like
it's just
hoping that
we can have those nuanced conversations
along the way without people being up in
arms and saying like you're uh a rape
apologist and it's like no i've been
raped yeah and i apologize for that
i'm very sorry formally but that's kind
of how i felt like with these girls like
they had not been like fully raped and
then this girl said
no really they hadn't i'm like i've been
through a different situation than you
like i really have like and she said
that um she told someone else that i
said and i have no memory of saying this
but i think it's so hilarious she said
that i said to her like unless you can't
be a feminist unless you've been raped
which i'm like it doesn't sound like
words that would come in my mouth but
it's so funny and i'm like i'm making a
t-shirt
but also it's like aren't we comedians
can't we like laugh and like yeah but
i'm i'm grateful like when i see this
girl we're fine like i had to do a lot
of work but she would always stomp and
be all mad around me i'm like girl we
have the best job in the world like no
hard feelings i'm no interested in being
friends with you i'm glad we're not
hanging out but you don't have to stomp
and be upset there's nothing to be doing
can i say something i that you because
you brought up the louis thing and this
was so long ago but it's making me
really realize why you and i will be
friends forever because when that
article came out we did not agree and we
thought yeah and then we would be like
we'd be like okay we're not i would say
like what should we not talk about it
but we stayed friends we still hung out
we still like i would never give a [ __ ]
if what someone we did not agree we did
not agree yes and it's not and it's like
and i don't need you to agree like i
want you to feel whatever you feel about
a situation i have no interest in i
don't need people around me that i like
to have open discussions and my opinion
on things can always change like i don't
i was not in the room i don't know what
happened i'm going off of what i read
you know so i don't know what happened
and i
i can't i would never sit here and say i
know how those girls fell or anything
like that all i can do is go through
like my lens of what i did and how i
felt about it and but i changed my mind
every day on things i'm loving
personally also a thing that happens in
that like culture as well is like a lot
of people will be like what you haven't
spoken out you haven't spoken out and
i in general i'm like you know what just
as you're talking this came to me like
i don't need to have an opinion on
everything because i don't really know
or it's not my business yeah like i
don't know or you're still thinking
about what you want to say you don't
need to smack it onto your like
facebook fee or your instagram feed
forever like the amount of people who
[ __ ] dm to me and tweeted at me and
essentially harassed me when like all
that news about julia came out i'm like
why am i looped in yeah i what they
don't because they murdered because jury
duty listen the amount of
every day one of our colleagues is
accused of [ __ ] molesting or raping
it's like it's like i'm on jury duty
every [ __ ] day it's like i already
sat in court i like
i but and it's like and then i get all
triggered and i'm like yeah like i'll
see a picture of one of them and i'm
also i'm like i'm putting on my suit
jacket and i got like a briefcase i'm
like we're going to court but i can't
that takes my piece that takes my piece
so i have to wake up every morning and
go do you know what i choose do you know
who i think is innocent or guilty
me i'm gonna just live my life and take
care of myself because i can't
i will add to that though that there is
some type of internalized misogyny if
you're placing the emotional burden on
the women that are working around these
men so now because you're playing jury
duty and now these men have done what
they've done now the emotional burden is
of on you to have this very well thought
out opinion and to have that in a social
or in a public platform that is
exhausting and then you're putting it
back on women yes
and i think that that in itself is a
misogynistic thing to do even from a
woman it is it's usually from when i
love women i love men it's usually from
you know you love women
it was a lot of women being like you
have to speak out you have to and it's
like i'm
i dropped out of college like i can't
make like a public statement that's
gonna be wonderful listen her twitter's
about like pancakes do you understand
there's not a lot going on here
[Music]
i love athletic greens you both got me
hooked on it yeah she drinks it before
her light walks
but it is crazy you so you drink it
every morning on an empty stomach right
mm-hmm and it the whole idea is like it
takes
the guesswork out of like having to
realize oh i ate this vegetable it's
like you get all the nutrients you need
in one drink right and if you're
somebody who does not necessarily love
the taste of vegetables and that's
something that's a part of your diet
every day this is just an easy way to
drink something delicious and to get all
of the nutrients and it's just it tastes
good and then you just have started your
day well and it's i like i take little
um travel packets with me on the road
yeah so i just because i'm always on the
road and because it's just hard like
with all of the jet lag and stuff i just
like to have consistency in some places
so athletic greens are always and with
one delicious scoop of athletic greens
you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and whole food source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right and this
blend of special this sorry this special
blend of ingredients supports your gut
health your nervous system your immune
system your energy recovery focus and
aging all of it which is really
important and nice to get that in one
place because otherwise then i spent all
day being like oh did i get enough
nutrition did i am i healthy like this
just
takes it all and if you have certain
food sensitivities or preferences
athletic greens is keto paleo vegan
dairy-free and gluten-free or
gluten-free you have that option yeah
and it costs less than three dollars a
day so you're investing in your health
and it's cheaper than a cold brew habit
also when you subscribe you get a
one-year supply of vitamin d and it
comes in this dropper it's my favorite
form of vitamin d i've ever had some
vitamin
also like i think my doctor told me that
most people don't know that they're
actually deficient in vitamin d i know
we live in california say for instance
everyone's like oh we have vitamin d but
most people aren't getting enough
vitamin d and with athletic greens they
give you this free little dropper full
and that dropper full they give you this
bottle of vitamin d and i take it every
day and i feel like it supports so much
of
the goodness inside me yeah it's really
easy to consume it that way you guys
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into flu and cold season it's
just one scoop in a cup of water every
day that's it it's so easy no need for
like a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
and to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free
one-year supply she lit up when she said
freeze
a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com tuesday again that is
athleticgreens.com tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
you guys need to see the movie men
immediately why it is like okay so it's
a horror movie and it's like i don't
want to give away anything but there's
undertones of like a theme of like micro
aggressive um
toxic masculinity i mean it was i was
livid afterwards
i was like the whole time i was like
smacking tattoos like they do do that
and then they do that
and it's not all men you know but they
have these different types of misogyny
that you hit and it was just like it was
just so such a weird crazy fun i love
the poster it looks like creepy but
we're all laughing like weird things
were happening we can go see it yeah it
was really fun because i usually don't
like going to the movies anymore but i
realize i have to go during the day so i
don't fall asleep you guys it was great
um
we're gonna switch the switch from men
to women real quick because something
i don't know if it's magical but
something really life-changing happened
to me um this past weekend
and i'm not just saying this this isn't
queer baiting like from the bottom of my
heart i fell madly in love with a
stripper esther are you okay
i relate so i feel good i i have fallen
in love with a stripper it was so
embarrassing because after the private
dance
she was like because during you know
what they'll say anything right like
when they're dancing for you but she was
saying things like hey like maybe we
should go like dive and like surf and
stuff and i believed her because it was
too very specific
and then and then
afterwards she didn't ask for my
information so i was like oh no it was
just part of the dance so you i did the
most the cringiest most embarrassing
thing i pulled up my instagram which i
had just deleted by the way to show her
i was like hey if you want to find me on
instagram just to show like my blue
check mark so maybe she would contact
them that we've all we've all done that
we've all done it you guys and nothing
cricket really
and she was i don't know what it was
about her but i was just like i had
stars what did she look like she was
i think she was
i don't want to say okay okay because
it's gonna if i give her the description
yeah she's um okay
um
so she was i think i was sitting i think
she looked to me like she was like oh
you got sunburned down there
um she was just she was i think you
would find her really attractive carlos
but her face it was her face don't you
think it's gonna be easy for her to give
birth look at this the baby would just
slide yeah i'm just gonna hug a tree and
just fart one out would you guys want to
have a home birth
i don't know why i'm asking you
i feel like i would want to plop it out
in a in a puddle
um
i think teacher just swim right away
third or fourth if i got to number three
i would probably um let one slide out of
me at home this is
carlos trying to pretend he's straight
he's like
one time uh me and dave went to a strip
club in vegas and like i walked around
and picked out a stripper to give him a
lap dance and afterwards i was like
doing everything i could to google and
like with her fake name and i like
eventually kind of found something that
was like her on like a a playboy
offshoot website or penthouse or
something
and yeah i'll always remember her
she does not remember you at all that's
for sure unless there's a restraining
order and then she has to remember for
her own safety but there is a heartbreak
involved in that because like
did you knit did you like plan your
like future with her in your head i
really did i was like we're going to be
on the beach together we're going to
like dive you know what you need what
you need wing woman yes you need us
okay what would you do
are the perfect duo we we will just make
fools of ourselves we'll annoy her so
much that she has to eat you out to get
away from us you guys i was so sad the
next day i got an iv infusion
and i never get one for emotional just
for my emotions i was like i'm feeling
really really down today and so i was
like oh i'm going to call your body we
got to get we should get ivs one episode
where they're just giving are you okay
with needles i can't yeah hell yeah no
no i'm not oh yeah i get tattoos now
because we i there was a mcdonald's in
the children's hospital i went to so
every time i went we got my were you the
clown what were you doing at the
children's hospital
were you the patch adams i was a very
sick kid not to brag but um no i love
shots and stuff were they just like
she's faking yeah
esther um
what age did you um age out of the
children's hospital because usually it's
like yeah you could probably still go
yeah so
you know i remember like when i turned
18 my general doctor was like your
genital doctor
that's what that's what ours
i wasn't lost by my doctor my
pediatrician was just like you know you
can still come for a few years you're
18. you can still
we can transition make the transition oh
my god they fell for it they thought you
were weak
but then when i moved to la so but i
still see the same doctor i've been
seeing since i was 21 here
dr schenderkar mine is dr villiamore
he's passed but oh
and now we're going to hear someone but
i haven't gone to him in a year
i go to mall doctors now you go to my
doctor i know but i he's you know my
doctor
oh i have some updates i uh but i want
to talk about lesbians first okay now
that we're talking about it because i
was thinking about how much i was having
like 90s appreciation i was at whole
foods the other day and they play
literally the best 90s music and the
number one 90s music is lesbian 90s
music indigo girls melissa etheridge
have you heard heart thrown into a
[ __ ] you can feel like the [ __ ]
quivering out of their mouth like they
like come to my window louis fair little
fair all of it tori amazon
but i was thinking and then it got me
thinking of my favorite kind of like
folky jewelry from back then and i got i
found it okay
and i want to bring it back before
because i know we're kind of sliding
into the 2000s now and before i want to
bring this back before the 90s are gone
my hands are ready i tried to get esther
silver one but
they just ignored me and gave me
ear humpers do you remember these noses
they you they're ear cuffs they're like
little men and or women i guess in this
case wait yeah i want mine to be a girl
and they go
and they cling to your
ear they come wait this is so cool yeah
aren't they awesome
they're so good and they just hump your
ear i didn't know this was a 90s thing
yeah
esther do you not know you're
as a as a woman who loves women do you
not know you're 90s lesbians not really
no because i was too young she was in
the children's hospital i was
downloading illegal pictures of naked
women on my aim or whatever i had
a wall isn't it good i love it
i know i try to get you silver but no i
love i love mixing metal mixes
um but i was just thinking like the just
the have you ever heard okay so you know
um this song by the dire straits romeo
and juliet
yes so there's like a million versions
of that the killers have one but the one
by the [ __ ] indigo girls is crazy
it's number one
it's the best version annie can you help
me have this hump my ear when i think of
90s i think of like spice girls i guess
maybe is that like late 90s
yes yes that is late 90s
that's me and carlos's childhood yeah
exactly thank god you had a sister so he
did all the girl things
yeah but i would guess well
carlos can do the girl things the the
equivalent of that late 90s um that is
probably from the little fair remnants
of it is probably like someone like
fiona apple uh
okay so i've been going to amoeba
records every weekend and by the way i'm
a celebrity there it's crazy
that we craft crossover
records and amoeba and trash tuesday go
together it's not what you want to hear
listen it's crazy the only person i know
who goes there's dave's dad and bobby
okay bobby's a big amoeba i mean we've
been having like the best time going
there we got the record play from the
the uh comedy story comedy anniversary
and so we've just been going every week
and it's been like and i'm just i really
want a fiona apple so bad
i want um what's the name of the album
which is her face um
i don't remember but what we got was we
got the magnolia soundtrack i got a
limited edition hundred dollars i was
easily dropped it the soundtrack and the
soundtrack has all these amy mann things
and it thanks
they thank fiona apple because fiona
apple was dating him when he made the
movie and was like his muse magnolia
soundtrack one of bobby's favorite
studios amy mann is just so like
just even the ending of that movie i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go on the 18th i
think to try i shouldn't be telling
people this but they're having it's like
um record day or something so they're
releasing things that have never been
released and i want to get the um
royal tenenbaum soundtrack
because that's never been released
onboard it's one of my favorite movies
any wes anderson film is probably even
the ones that aren't good are good
even the
you know who i befriended was um [ __ ]
what's his name the reason i don't
remember your name is because you
[ __ ] unfollowed me [ __ ] uh the kid i
did a movie with him um
the long dumb road tony
he would play the little kid in the um
what was the one in the hotel
the russ anderson hotel the oh the kid
from spider-man yeah tony tony reverend
oh the guy from the the budapest one
yeah funny
yeah i know he's great he didn't follow
yeah that's so funny maybe maybe annie
is like too far for the tom holland
zendaya spider-man world
maybe maybe but that's a good thing
they'll grow up they'll grow up one day
[Laughter]
you guys carlos came to the midwest with
me and he spent the weekend at my
parents house and i think
this third this was the second time he's
come and actually be there and we were
there longer and i think my parents
officially don't respect him because
they were really fully themselves
and are you okay like i feel like you
could have a lawsuit again i guess that
is the case like if they respected me
they would have been like on their best
behavior yeah they were on their worst
was your dad doing beds
no that's like respect level like not
respect level is like
criticizing my order at a restaurant or
oh i love these people maybe they just
respect me so much they're treating you
like [ __ ] to like impress me
well carlos ordered chicken tenders at
portillo's and the whole time my dad was
roasting them he was like oh does that
come with a toy are you are you eating
that coffee that's what skinny people
eat no that's funny though that's like
he's just being funny no totally he was
just being funny but also to go to
portillo's and just get chicken tenders
it's sacrilegious it is weird but
he got the beef sandwich yeah but i
didn't eat all of it but i also if i go
to the midwest and there's like crap in
front of me or the south or anywhere
it's like i need to order like the salad
yes i've been ordering very healthy at
comedy clubs and they look at me like i
am absolutely crazy what do you get i do
chicken tenders and like a salad i don't
even do the tenders anymore because i'm
not
this is like here's the thing
this okay the egg freezing diet
leading into my tmj diet has actually
been so good for me because i do need a
doctor to tell me
like i do because otherwise i'm like
it's fun to eat funyuns like and i do
that's my heart like my heart is like
white trash eating like
fried cheesecake do you know what i mean
like this is i'm from philly we like
cheese steaks we like cheese whiz like
it's just
it's like a part of my identity that i'm
breaking right now because i do want to
live long i want to be healthy every
time i realize like every time when i
was like um
thought i was dying on the toilet when i
thought i was elvising i knew i wasn't
gonna die because i really have this
vision of myself like being the most
amazing elderly woman like
same level of annoying but like just old
and
light hopefully likable but just like i
see myself peaking in my like late 80s
my early 90s so i just have that image
so i'm like i do want to do the things
that prepare me for that yeah i do want
to like not so you've almost died on a
toilet you've almost died on a toilet
and i think get on the toilet collapse
we just start poking her for a long time
people made fun of elvis for dying on a
toilet but i think it is you know a good
final resting place because like in the
philippines we don't call them restrooms
we don't call them bathrooms we call
them
rest in peace rooms no we see our we
call them comfort rooms
um and i think that when we're feeling
ill or whatever it is a very natural
thing to go find a toilet to die it is
comfortable you know how dogs go off
into the woods we just go to take a [ __ ]
yeah our final defecation
i think so i think there's something to
that it's not a bad place like it's
you're it's comfortable it's familiar
like i'd rather be there than many
places by the way i'm having the image
of randy trying to go into the woods and
me being like
you're dying in my arms
um carlos also came with on a drive-by
past my ex's house how's the house
looking
does it have a no esther sign
is the color the same have they changed
the sightings well i wasn't there 20
years ago or whatever but it was weird
because we were almost at esther's house
and then she was like wait we have to go
back and like do a u-turn and go on
another loop to find this guy's house
yeah my parents they you make them go
too oh yeah my mom drives every time and
dad in the front seat we were in the
back oh there's a book about enabled
that's all you are is enabled that's
what all your problems are that's
also carlos pointed out that i want to
share this he you what did you say that
you can see why i am the way i am
yeah it's like well you can say it this
is also enabling say it that my mo it's
like you can't even try to help because
you almost get in trouble like my mom
right tell them
was carlos like no i'll fold her laundry
and then no literally like her mom was
like weirded out by the way i was doing
things because i was doing it so messy
and i wouldn't let her help me but like
esther isn't like
allowed to do anything like we had
coffees all right and like she took our
coffees and dumped them out and put them
in the trash can but it's like we
weren't even allowed to do that so it's
i can see how esther can be really lazy
or need like 50 assistants because like
her mom raised her to not even do things
on her own
but like you know this already and this
could have been fixed like 15 [ __ ]
years ago
i like when carlos fights back
that does make sense and i think that
i can relate slightly because
while my mom was she was a helicopter
mom right very like abusive and what not
i was not allowed to feed myself with my
own spoon until i was 13 because it was
a control thing so i was spoon-fed until
i was about 13. wait that's
serious that's child abuse yeah that's
very serious yeah so it wasn't the same
spoon she was whipping you with yes i
could not choose what i would eat it was
going to be six tomatoes pork chop with
rice a big glass of milk every morning
and i had to eat every morsel pork for
breakfast yes but very island style but
um because she was i was her race horse
right so i had to she was like you're
you're an athlete you have to be taking
these many calories but what happened
was it was a built-in um
um she rendered me useless yeah as a
teenager for a very long time so what
happened when finally i was in america
and she was like oh you got to do [ __ ]
for yourself i'm like i don't know how
yeah you think i'm going to clean my
rabbit [ __ ] all over my room i love pet
rabbit i'm like yeah no i don't know how
i don't know how to move i don't know i
have no autonomy does any part of you
miss that because the pet rabbit
the rabbit poop like being spoon fed i
know that's like an extreme but it does
you're so jealous like someone picks out
all the food for you like you make no
decisions like no i missed you guys i
don't want to bring up i don't want to
bring up the colonic again but you know
you can just get the [ __ ] sucked out of
the ass right it takes all the good
floor out too
yeah yeah i don't want to i miss my good
flora now esther that makes sense for me
because i had a very um
big crisis as a teenager because i felt
number one like i didn't just didn't
know how to do anything so i doubled
down and i made sure that i learned to
do everything on my own by the time i
was 17 i'm like i'm moving out i'm
getting my own place i'm paying my own
rent and i got out of my and then they
just like moved in with you yeah like
great we're moving in cool we have a new
place because i was then aware that i
was like i haven't been allowed to do
anything make any decisions for myself
including like if i would fold a t-shirt
she would undo it and then re-fold it
that's my mom too exactly my mom
wouldn't do that but she would try to
get us to do chores and we'd be like
mavic and she would just do it she would
always make like chore charts and then
but she would end up doing anything and
then i realized like i just had a really
good hypnosis session that like
has just literally cured me of every
self-sabotage in my life it's so insane
i realized what it was in this session
when i was a kid and i would get i was
such a perfectionist just from like
honestly it was like verbal abuse when i
was a kid which i totally forgive my dad
for i forget you know what i mean but he
was very very very hard on me and very
very verbally abusive not physically
and so i got in my head that i'm like an
idiot or whatever so then when i wasn't
doing things perfect it would like
reaffirm that and i remember
um if i wouldn't write like if my
handwriting wasn't neat i would like
stab the paper
i would get so mad at myself
and for not being perfect and then so my
mom would see me like having these like
internal battles with myself
when i started like at the level of
writing papers like fifth grade sixth
grade and she was like i would get to a
place where i'd be like it's not perfect
the first line wouldn't be perfect and i
would start to freak out and my mom
would be like want to save me and she'd
she's like alright i'll sit with you
and we can write it together which i was
like okay good then it's someone like
helping me kind of be calm but then she
would just rewrite the whole thing she
would just write it and then i never got
to feel like the joy of like finishing a
project and stuff like that and i know
it was coming from a sweet place she was
just trying to help and kind of like
calm the waters and stuff but i realized
it really taught me
like i just had low self-worth in my
like ability to get work done and now
i'm like
i'm remembering i used to be like a
[ __ ] poet when i was a kid no offense
but i would like when they would give me
my word my vocabulary word i would
always like write a poem or something
and and i liked writing and i and now
i'm like remembering that i had like joy
in that and i'm i've just had like the
best week of writing jokes and going
through all my [ __ ] and it's just crazy
it's just so weird how like something
that you're told when you're
four can stick with you for so long
having debt is very stressful what do
you know about debt like i know well i
don't know like you know it but i was
broke for 10 years before this podcast
started
i shared a studio apartment with a woman
and i believe at one point you were
going to join us so
don't come for me
um
and it can be hard to see the light at
the end of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can be
even harder to ask for help and that's
where upstart comes in yeah i've
definitely been in those places where i
have so much debt in so many places that
i'm just like i'm gonna just ignore this
until it goes away
and that is not it doesn't actually go
away it doesn't help really man but it's
human nature to not want to face a
difficult hard thing so we put it off
but it
it's that's not helpful upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date and look
upstart knows that you're more than your
credit score thank god because mine was
69 weirdly enough well then you are your
credit i know
um
so rather than looking at your credit
score alone upstart's model considers
other factors like your income
employment or other information provided
in your loan application to find out a
smarter rate for your loan and it's
really convenient you can check your
rate in minutes for loans between 1 000
to 50 000 without impacting your credit
score you can even receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan you guys don't wait and check your
rate today at upstart.com tuesday
that's upstart.com tuesday to check your
rate today don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application so go to upstart.com
tuesday
[Music]
i can't even imagine how bad of a mom i
could be like it's like i don't even go
there when people like when i was
pregnant people were like oh you'll be
such a good mom i was like what are you
talking about
like three people said that i was like
out of the thousands i told no
but yeah i fully am prepared that
parenting
will be
not great
but i think that that is an honest like
i when people are like i'm going to be
the best mom i'm like already you're
going to be the worst that's a really
bad sign well i will say the reason i'm
going to be an elderly mother is because
i was not up until the past couple years
even able to allow myself to imagine
having kids because i was so angry
i had so much anger in me and i was
getting so like triggered so fast and
stuff that i was like i can't do this to
a kid there's no
how would i how would i not take that
anger on my kid that's what i learned
from my parents you know and they now
have like
they grew out of it you know my parents
did work on themselves they grew out of
it they're they can handle their anger
now so i had that example at least to
realize that i could work on myself and
then when i really realized i had a
problem and that's why i'm like never
angry at like really that angry at my
exes and stuff because it's like
whatever toxicity they brought out in me
was
like a good lesson for me to learn you
know it was like i purged some stuff and
was able to work on it
goddamn those kids would have been
[ __ ] up
same if i got if i didn't schmore i got
uh my results of my embryos what do you
mean how many do we have what species
four
they're human
not the odds one is not like
really good
okay
uh isn't there like three tiers like can
i have
you don't know and like not that good
there was like a bigger one
yeah but here's the thing and then
there's three that are like
like really good so the good ones are 65
to 75 percent though work okay and then
the other one is 35 so
but
they are
all boys
shut up annie all boys i hope they're
gay
i hope they're all i do too
and i hope that they're comfortable
saying it
it's so weird well you could always go
again but but then no i'm not gonna go
again
but then i was thinking about it and i
was like let's have them all today i
know
but then i was like maybe i should
donate like because it is weird i feel
like to just have them so maybe i should
like donate one to
a gay couple or something oh
would you really
give one up i i i'm thinking about it
just because ethically the whole thing
feels very like a little bit weird to me
even though i know it's not like a full
thing yet or whatever but it feels like
if there are people that are like really
dying to have a kid
but i guess they could adopt too i don't
know well people sell don't people sell
eggs and embryos all the time like
that's not
i feel like it's just weird territory
i'm in and i never thought i was gonna
make enough money to even be here and
now i'm like
past it and i'm like what did i do i
mean i'm happy with it but how does todd
feel he's really excited yeah wait but
how would you feel if like let's say you
you gave one of these it would be so
weird that's what i'm saying yeah i
can't i would feel weird too like
especially if you did it before you guys
had your video oh i would i couldn't do
it before
wait i i kind of would just to see yeah
like you know i just picked it like
actually i want that one can i have a
bag yeah you raised it cute it dresses
good imagine if you gave one and that
one's like the cute one the well they
give you like when you're before you do
the procedure you have to sign all these
things and
and i and they had an option where it's
like you could leave your embryos in the
in the case that todd and i both die
because it's weird it's like a weird
creep i know
it's so real and i'm like i was watching
randy like randy likes to like hump his
toy but he wants to be touching me too
and i'm like oh my god is this my future
like little jerk-off boys there's gonna
be little crunchy socks everywhere you
are a boy mom i'm a boy yes
[Laughter]
well congrats on your boys annie isn't
that so crazy um carlos i wanna i have
so many questions for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can i have the bug i want to eat it
shut up yeah i want to
oh you want it on your banana
i'll eat it after banana breakfast
okay um carlos
i have questions for you yeah um are you
guys i realized that
you know you're kind of this guy who's
always just been
the sweetest gay
sweetest most accommodating you're like
an emotional support animal for a lot of
us for women like you're not trying to
[ __ ] them yeah
you're around it's like you're kind of
into like very much a safe harbor a
different genre how long were you
married
yes
yes this is coming up because i told her
how your dad asked us at holy freeholy
like let's get personal carlos you know
what let's get personal my dad literally
goes so why did you get divorced and
then i said i was too high to talk about
which i was i took like 300 milligrams
i was like floating what happened in
that marriage that you had to take 300
milligrams what happened
i
here's i feel like if you're married to
me you get everything paid for
but what
if you're like i was like where's my
payments
but if you're just like a hot girl who i
had a crush on and we dated like three
or four years in i'm gonna wanna go
downstairs and like watch tv by myself
because i don't really like you anymore
after four years how old were you when
you were married why did you um decide
that she was the one you wanted to marry
how long were you together before you
proposed we were together six months
before i proposed whoa
yeah can i speak actually as someone who
was his best friend
i was like
well we're about we've been sounds like
i died and you're talking about me at my
funeral we've been very close for a long
time and i remember like a few of us
being like carlos is getting like it's
he's just it felt strange to me he's
young it was new anyway so i keep going
i think it's like when you're young
and
i think when you're like under 30 you
can just like you feel like you can do
whatever you want if you have like
access to funds to do it and
uh he's got rich boy problems exactly so
he was born you felt strong about her i
did but i should have just been her
boyfriend for like two years but she
said yes and was was it a big wedding
was it was it a big yes was she into
you'd probably was it a figure yeah
that's a great question no it's real
um
i think it was a medium yes actually she
was like
boy boy because does anyone okay this is
it wasn't like oh
what i want to know too like does anyone
propose to their girlfriend and the
girlfriend say no and then they just
carry on like yes
[Applause]
stand up they just stand up and they're
like
all right let's go get pizza i guess
i'll go return this ring
do you know john dewalt proposed to his
his girlfriend she said no when they
stayed together and then like you're
they they're like they're married now i
know i'm like i was so impressed with
her saying he stayed with her well no
it's more like i don't think i'm there
yet or
if i said that 10 years in oh my god
that would be
a horrible thing but if let's say i got
proposed to in six months i would be
like hey like
like i love you but this is fast and i'm
not there yet i really like where we're
going can we you know can we
rain check yeah but that's like a mature
response
like when two parties aren't mature
they're not going to make a mature
decision how did you propose i actually
don't know that inner prius
okay yeah
in her penis
her prius oh her prius
like you just busted the ring out and
yeah but i shouldn't i mean it was like
a priest was it on your couch i hated it
it wasn't a [ __ ] ring did you see it
coming
no so it was six months in wait wait no
i think she did because you don't just
propose to someone out of the blue
because that's kind of rude and how long
were you married for
three or four years how many of those
years would you say you were positive
and that you really had it's like half a
half
and was there fighting or just not into
each other there's like arguing no
because we were into each other like we
had sex while separated like that wasn't
the issue is more like
just arguing
arguing like i'm just not someone you
want to argue with if like
yeah i'm just i can't imagine you being
argumentative i can i can
no i think you're
i think you dig deep too like i think
you cut deep yeah i was yeah exactly
like in fights like i would say things
that were so mean she would be like oh i
should be the only person you're not
that mean to and in my head i'm like but
it's funny and it doesn't matter
i'm like
well i i just feel like you know what i
never liked no she do you know what i'm
thinking i think she's right [ __ ] you up
in a fight yeah i could [ __ ] you up in a
fight what you and me if we were already
we have to destroy you yeah but it's
never real
we've never gone
if you've ever taken me seriously i'm
always kidding we've never been in a
real fight
annie is probably like one of my only
matches in a fight ooh sexual tension
are we back to carlos oh my god we've
circled back
i think he said perfect i don't know it
was something juicy or something
carlos were you devastated
or were you in acceptance i was pretty
when i was dating todd
[Laughter]
um
i was really upset and sad
and i knew that it was right because i
was mostly sad about losing my dogs
and that's a huge consideration that
really was but for me it was more like
wait a second i just got out of being
married
i just turned like 31 or something
like i got this actually you do i got
this cool new hairdo yeah i was never
worried about you i'm ready to go sleigh
puss is this long
did you go to the wedding yes i went to
the wedding was it a big wedding
normal size it was like a good sized one
she but she didn't like you she did not
like me like how she did which is a bad
sign though to not like your funny
friend i think a big red flag is not
liking like if you're the girl not
liking the guy's like best girlfriend or
whatever like if you're dating me if
you've already come into the
relationship with this girlfriend like i
can understand being a little weary if
someone gets a new female friend and
that you're like all right well you're
giving like the energy to them that you
should be giving to this relationship
i had that in that relationship i was
friend i was like becoming friends with
this girl ali siegel who was like real
who's like funny on twitter who
yesterday
and like my ex-wife was really upset
about that and that was like a big red
flag for me because i was like yo this
is like a writer girl like it doesn't
mean were you attracted to her though of
course
she just she just read you right yeah
yeah and i think that um there are ways
to be friends with women and not make
them feel what she was feeling i think i
just would never if someone's like mary
if a guy's married or something like
definitely at this like i would never
not like befriend his wife yeah equally
i always i'm like can i come to your
house for dinner or like i never want to
like be like a surprise to the wife like
i feel like i only hung out with you
guys like
once or twice and it just i felt like i
was
i feel bad talking about this but i feel
like i was i don't remember perfectly
but it's like i was trying
and she just got the vibe like she just
didn't want to know me at all and i was
like okay
also like sometimes it's got to be hard
like if you're in a relationship like i
remember yeah my ex-boyfriend before we
started dating when we were just friends
he would be like dating these girls and
we just got along so well like we would
just be laughing and we were best
friends so it's like so then they're
like wait why are you having like more
fun with her
yeah and it was just like so maybe it
was that you guys just have a better
rapport than you had with your wife but
of course i have a better rapport with
esther i've known her for so much longer
and she's funny it's like friend group
together and yeah yeah but no girl like
date will be funnier than like you guys
or anything so like
good luck finding her i um so you are
gay
when
when i first started dating dave
i was very much pro i was i shouldn't
judge your ex-wife because i was like
that with dave like he didn't even have
female friends but if he did i would
have like
i would be responsible for their deaths
like
it would be bad so i don't judge her i
had in college a guy who i was like who
was like she was hotter than me so it's
like what are you what is this yeah no i
had i had a i had a
guy i was dating in college who he was
like really close with this one girl and
it wasn't even like i was mad i was just
like
date
yeah like date each other what if you
like why there doesn't make any sense
you wouldn't be dating they were both
like good-looking people they like loved
hanging out with each other like they
were just each other's speed like i just
was like this thing that came in that
didn't match anything i was like
i just i i have some goss for you there
is a girl that you know who i absolutely
have no respect
for even to this day
i'll tell you why in the beginning of me
and bobby's relationship the first year
he didn't really understand
um what would hurt me what would not
hurt me and what was inappropriate or
maybe he didn't he just didn't he was
trying to test he was trying to like
test me
and this girl we know in common um they
would always have this like flirtatious
banter and i'm like okay you have you're
a comedian you i i hope to god you have
females
this is the the exact type of woman i
really have trouble
like feeling any kind of like warm
feelings towards even in my most like
pragmatic state of mind i'm like wait no
you are a disrespectful [ __ ] straight
up also false just not a real thing yeah
in uh about two years into early or a
year and a half into our relationship
they always had a friendly banter and
bobby was always like you know um she's
just a friend she's just a friend but
she would really cross the line like on
texting and say things like you're a
king like wish we had you know wish we
had a shot before blah blah blah
and then but then bobby and i one of the
reasons why people don't know this one
of the reasons why we broke up early on
is because i saw a string of messages
basically saying i i want to raw dog you
shut up to her
why i was hoping to him to her not
[Laughter]
look at your messy car like how would
you stick a condom on right and um
you know like this is early on in a
relationship a lot i tell you this much
bobby put me through
emotional psychological health he's dead
to all of us
you guys because when i would get the
text because he lent me his old phone
that was still it was like his back
phone and i was like why are you doing
he's so dumb about these things so his
messages would still pop up and i was
reading it on the phone that i was
borrowing about him wanting to raw dog
this girl that's so funny and this is
what i would do i would go up to him i
would say hey
this isn't okay and i'll be crying this
hurts me he's like i didn't write that
oh why i didn't try to try that off it's
so cute and then i fell into this like
deep depression and how he remembers
that he was like i knew that i had like
broken you because there was one time
when i went into the second bedroom of
our condo he's like i went in there and
you were just like staring at yourself
in the mirror in the dark and i knew
that you were deliberating like what the
[ __ ] am i still doing here and i was
like honestly i was probably listening
to amy mann i was like i probably was
like really peter pan
and then we finally had this big blowout
over ikea dishes and we tell people yeah
we had us we broke up once because it
was over ikea dishes but it was over the
fact that he had such poor [ __ ]
manners when it came to like not making
you you know he's so funny prioritized
like he would go to canada and he would
randomly post pictures with a girl in
like a photo booth and i'm like who is
this oh my gosh
so i have a similar thing um when i was
21 and i first started dating i noticed
there was a girl at the comedy store who
every time i was around tony and
everyone knew we were dating she would
touch him
she would touch his arm she would touch
his chest and laugh and i remember i and
keep in mind i was 21 i just dropped out
of school like i hadn't had adult things
i hadn't had like adult interactions yet
and i just remember feeling
like
what is she doing like she knew this
person knows that's my boyfriend why are
you touching my boyfriend in front of me
what's the point of that and it made me
so mad and i was like i
i don't like this person now i'll never
i would never do that already
but she's also just not a she's not a
girl's girl doesn't like you either
no this is the same girl that when i got
past at the comedy store by the way when
i got past the comedy store i got passed
right away i did not know what the
comedy story was i remember
only cool girl only cool girls get that
that's awesome so i came in from new
york i didn't know that the comedy store
was like everyone was like who's this
girl she just got passed overnight or
whatever i walked in one audition
immediately was passed and i [ __ ] was
good
but i think the reason i got past is
because i didn't i had no pressure on me
i just thought it was a regular audition
for a regular club like i was like
whatever i was like of course i'll get
past so i got passed
i didn't even know it was a thing okay
and when you see this thing it's like
there are a lot of people that work
there hang out there that they're just
waiting for their shot to be passed like
it's a big deal to these people it takes
a long time and you know sometimes
the cream rises um
the mint chocolate chip ice cream rises
the spray tan rises
but anyway so this girl was passed
already okay so then i meet another girl
who is a long gone mutualish friend of
all of ours
um and she was like yeah when you first
got past this girl was like let's go to
the comedy store and watch annie bomb
i'm like who is this match
but i never but it was fun
well it's like you know so obviously and
so clearly that that was that person's
insecurity yeah talking and it had
nothing to do with you but but at the
time if i heard someone say that about
me i'd just be like
why don't you hear like who are you
but also who knows i probably bummed
but probably also very nice to your face
otherwise like that girl who bobby
wanted to raw dog i would see her at
like um caa events and parties and she
would be she would just you could tell
that she had done something wrong
because she was just like you're so
beautiful let's hang out and have a
drink i'm like [ __ ] i read it all i
really wanted to say that i'm like i
know all about it you know
um
this other one we were talking about she
would always come up she'd be like you
unfollowed me i'd be like yes i
unfollowed you on instagram and i'll do
it again she's like follow me i'm like
i'm just gonna i'm following you
i'm just i'm fine you guys you know we
can never make fun of carlos's bald head
anymore right well thankfully we don't
have an hr department but it's
considered sexual harassment
in the workplace we've sexually harassed
him we do sexually harass him but in
england the courts are ruling that it's
sexual harassment why
because it's mean
yeah and it puts them down listen no be
mean on the internet i don't want anyone
to forget oh yeah petition guys no be
mean so but if it's in real life it's
look at this calling calling men bald
counts is sexual harassment why the uk
judges a uk judge rules wait can i
explain to you why that's disrespectful
to bald headed men yeah it's saying that
it's make that it's unsexy to be bald
it's like it's sexualizing the hair on
your head and the number one uk freaking
action star is jason statham the [ __ ]
king of bald men he probably is behind
this
i won't be bullied one more time
how do you feel if you are called bald
do you feel sexually harassed i don't
feel sexually harassed i just feel
harassed yeah but you're asking for
you're you have the most obviously bald
hair what if i say something like i want
to come on oh my god your bald head is
that sexual harassment i want to see you
i think it is technically but i don't
care i want to see you queef at him and
his hair like quizzes
carlos i love that you're wearing a
starface pimple patch oh thank you i had
one oh that's a pimple patch it's a very
very cute place to have a pimple because
then you could just turn it into a mole
really which is what we used to do in
the 90s eyeliner suspiciously a cute
place is that
a real pimple or is that just a there's
no
pimple comes off when he takes it off
it's
drawn on
[Laughter]
well i didn't want to put it like right
here
like for the recordings i didn't want to
draw attention or anything but i'm going
to put one right there after one right
here
wow yeah this is really interesting
you wanna eat the water bug annie yeah i
mean i don't want to
[Music]
all right i'm just doing it because i
said i would
i don't want to call it's not looking oh
my god i'm not eating the whole thing
okay who eats can you can you show the
camera annie but not me what i know what
it's gonna taste like they all [ __ ]
taste the same and they don't taste good
yeah
real size okay
[Music]
all right i just like to get through my
fears i think i come out on oh my god oh
my god oh my god don't look what are you
smelling
is she really
colliding who eats these who eats these
can you tell me because i feel like if i
don't look at it and someone should
shove it in my mouth i can swallow it
but if i
if i get a visual all right
i want a drum roll i want to wait people
in southeast asia sometimes they're
boiled or fried okay hold on hold on let
me film this
can i close my eyes and maybe someone
can just shove it in my mouth i'll shove
it in something do you want me to here
are you gonna shove it in her mouth no
no no annie eat it first what do i get
do i get a reward
um my life's already a reward guys every
day's my birthday there's really nothing
i need
no she's doing it oh my god she's biting
it like it's a [ __ ]
oh my god
i'm gonna throw
oh my god it's crunching like a doritos
oh i don't like the sounds you guys
the sounds are not great for me
okay
taste wise annie just give me a rating
is it swallowed yes
still you're disgusting you [ __ ] free
okay
what the hell just happened
what happened she spit it out and she
burped it up and it's in the wall just a
piece fell off no okay wait
why did you know he's a boy
wait kalila keep your eyes closed i'm
gonna put some in here
why am i gonna dance
i do not trust you carlos yeah carlos
here's here's um i i want to be a big
girl i want to be a big girl hey
hang on you guys
tell me it's something tell me what it
okay it's gonna
also i don't want to swallow it is it
okay if i just crunch it i think you
need to swallow it but you didn't
swallow it either i swallowed the whole
thing one piece but i spit it out okay
don't crunch it esther are you gonna be
the one to put it in my mouth yeah is
going to do it
esther is the most trustworthy
just
wait no we just have to do it like the
vaccine you just gotta go just keep your
eyes closed do you think i was afraid of
the vaccine or a shot that's six
boosters
all right hang on
okay
okay how are you gonna put it in
don't worry she's just gonna just open
her mouth and just go for it
tell me it's something else okay it's
something else it's a scorpion just say
it's a scorpion it's a scorpion it's a
scorpion it's just a scorpion you guys
it's just
okay go ahead
oh she bit me
good [ __ ]
good [ __ ] you raped her that's rape
what you did to her
i just sexually assaulted you you
sexually assaulted her and you deserve
to get hurt carlos delete the taste
wait i opened my mouth and i was almost
i was going to crunch down on your lips
you bit me esther careful
that was the most rejected i've ever
felt because you didn't know it was
gonna be me kissing you and i did and
you're like helio don't do it
i was like did she peek
i was like she must be peeking i just
kalila i don't want you to be too scared
but part of it came out of andy's mouth
and is now on the wall
it just looks like tar oh my god i'm
like
at least i got a kiss you had a bite you
had a bite i loved it i feel
accomplished i feel like i got through
something it took me a week to really
get myself worked up for it i can't
believe you came back strong and i was
ready to do it how did you get yourself
there i would have done it last week but
i wasn't supposed to eat before my
colonic
are you sure cockroaches don't count
how you guys feeling right now
i feel great i feel protein i feel
i feel like i'm
back in a childlike state of terror
where they used to
fly into my hair and i would have
crushed it
they would eat at my shins they would be
in the middle of my textbooks
i wonder what it is you know here's what
i think guys
my next tattoo is going to be of a
cockroach okay it's going to be a
cockroach a pigeon and a rat can you get
it going into your mouth
i think that that's i i think ultimately
i have so much respect for them the fact
that they can live without their heads
for 20 days the fact that they've
probably lived through like prehistoric
times the fact that they just really
don't know how to die
that's really sweet of you also roaches
are um
josh potter's fans he calls them roaches
isn't that cute that it's roaches and
slugs
oh
well um my heart rate whatever
happens to your body when bad things
happen that's what i'm going through
right now i don't feel good um
so i think that's time to go home i feel
great we started out with you kind of
not feeling good and we got back and we
got back to it and now i feel very good
her feeling bad does make me feel good
that's why we're good friends
we balance each other out kleila thank
you for being brave
eddie was the bravest one no but i
already was gonna be are you do you feel
sexually harassed by me um no
if i had i known i would have puckered
up and
give you a full one well next time well
baldy baldy cakes over there how did
baldy cakes feel
i don't feel sexually harassed just
harassed but it doesn't you want it you
would cut if you didn't want to get
attention for your bald weird looking
head you would shave a little crispy
this is like what rape is saying like
you wanted to ask no he is asking for
the beating
why do you keep it long and scraggly
because i had it shaved for so long i
just wanted to like rebel against that
right rebel against what society thinks
is attractive
and that's how you know he's calling me
unattractive
i can't wait for the next we have to do
another live because the wigs that i
have in store for you
they're wild the wigs i mean
the wig budget is by the way guys the
wig budget is more than any other budget
on this show
i'm dropping cash for this do you think
the celines are expensive wait till you
see these wigs you guys thank you so
much today has been a wild ride and we
really hope that you comment and
subscribe and show support and share our
show with your friends we want to grow
and take over
all the other podcasts bye you guys bye
guys
do you want us to do it i think that i
want to be brave like annie i just need
you to tell me it's something if so then
this is a bravery yeah i cannot see it
just shove it in my mouth once again you
just want to finish carlos or esther
actually i i trust you esther
i feel like annie would just like lob in
inside me i actually physically can't
[ __ ] i'll do it i can do it oh my god
i'm gonna do it the cute side first
where it's not as gross
it's just don't say sides are what it is
yeah
it's a scorpion tail
um tarantula
it's a it's a piece of beef jerky uh
i love beef jerky
yeah it's just jerky annie that's just
jerky listen joe rogan mind over my mind
over matter mine over matter okay this
is fear factor you're gonna win a
million dollars okay a million dollars
annie just don't shove it in just let me
just okay i'm placing it in front of you
open your mouth
and just crunch
open wide now
this is not comedy this is abuse
you're sick
i put your right hand down
now open your mouth it's a scorpion it's
a scorpion it's just a scorpion from the
island
this is like not fun
okay it's a scorpion it's a scorpion
it's a scorpion scorpion scorpion
[Music]
you did it you did it you did it
you did it
you did it everyone's puking i'm fine i
don't know
what you just did is can i tell you
something something's really weird with
you
why did you want to do it
you're [ __ ] up i think it's because
i'm so terrified of it that like yes i
want to wait for fear i want to wait out
i really want a way out they've just
terrorized my life for so long
and i'm not kidding you like
they're they're called water bugs
because they make water come out of your
eyes they're [ __ ] cockroaches let's
just call it what it is
[Music]
you